et pour en parler richard cojean médecin
anesthésiste réanimateur au sein de l'
ong à lima nous a rejoint bonjour merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors pour commencer l'afrique ne
représente que 5% des contaminations
dans le monde
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'expliquer
selon aussi un bon jour les 5%
effectivement c'est ce qui est
objectivement a rapporté c'est à dire
des cas testés et qui sont confirmées
mais c'est pratiquement c'est clair
qu'il ya plus des cas calé 5% qui est
rapportée on l'a déjà pas mal rapportées
par plusieurs autres experts la capacité
au global de testing sur l'afrique elle
est très très faible
voilà mais est-ce que selon vous le
virus y circulent de la même manière
qu'en europe
par exemple les virus sur l'afrique le
virus circule de la même manière qui est
sûre les rock intense mans
tout porte à croire qu'il ya eu
plusieurs contaminations qui ne sont
objectives et part à cause du fait qu'il
ya la capacité tester les faibles les
virus circulent intensément
effectivement pour l'afrique alors
malgré les signaux positifs de ces
derniers jours l'om est recommande donc
de la prudence que craignent très
concrètement les autorités sanitaires la
crainte c'est que c'est clair comme on
l'a vu dans votre reportage
l'epic on peut dire que les pic a été
atteint il ya une stabilité au global et
que ça baisse ça baisse et ça c'est ça
mon ces unités salle que ça baisse
il faut que ça continue à baisser mais
il faut rester très très prudent parce
que comme je le disais les virus
continue a continué à circuler et qui
est la capacité à tester est faible
cette capacité on voit les politiques
qui s'oriente vers le test ciblées sur
le mouvement c'est-à-dire dépassons qui
voyagent qui est que sur sur la
population globale
donc il faut continuer à rester très
vigilant parce qu'on sait que les la
capacité de les systèmes de santé en
afrique est faible il faut continuer à
rester très vigilant parce que l'impact
des cdc provident c'est aussi tous les
tous les autres pathologies en tout
toutes les autres tous les autres
problèmes de santé en afrique qui sont
qui sont pas trés trés adressé sur
lesquels on à part on n'est pas
structurée pour répondre correctement
donc il faut rester vigilant que
l'impact de coûts vide ne faiblisse
davantage les faibles système de réponse
les faibles et systèmes de gestion en
flux en tout cas aujourd'hui
les hôpitaux ne sont pas débordés par le
nombre de patients qui pourraient
affluer
oui mais ça on sait quand on parle des
décos vidant vous savez on est en
période hors afrique
je prends par exemple le sahel c'est la
période d'intense transmission du
paludisme et c'est la période de soudure
comme on l'appelle la malnutrition mais
on n'y a pas quelques vides qu'on voit
un autre en hospitalisation mais on ne
voit pas aussi c'est raz-de-marée sur le
paludisme par exemple sur la
malnutrition sur sur les autres
problématiques il je pense qu'il est
clair que à cause du fait de la crainte
par rapport au vide
les gens hésitent hésite d'aller des
consultés et d'aller à une
hospitalisation
donc les problèmes mais aussi à ce
complexe sur l'afrique il faut adresser
tous les problèmes et surtout le
problème restait vigilant sur les
complications l'impact de l'éco vide sur
les autres pathologies notamment qui qui
qui voilà qui doivent être adressées
aussi sur l'afrique voilà il est aussi
cette interrogation peut-être pour
conclure comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
expliquer que certains pays soient
beaucoup plus touchés que d'autres
je pense notamment à l'afrique du sud ou
encore au maroc c'est là je pense que
nous prenons c'est que de chercher soi
que l'afrique sont investissent beaucoup
dans la recherche pour arriver à vic est
mythique et objectivement sinon on va en
rester là dans des suppositions mais il
faut il faut vraiment qu'on investit sur
l'afrique pour arriver à comprendre déjà
au global pourquoi l'africain meurent
moins que par exemple le sud-américain
qui est avec un les nord-américains à
lui il faut cliquer sur base des
évidences scientifiques qui est de faire
des analyses très très apparentes
voilà merci beaucoup richard cojean
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur rt
franc je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
anesthésiste réanimateur pour les ong à
lima